مع زيادة النشاط في القطب الشمالي
، أصبح من المهم أكثر من أي وقت مضى
ضمان سلامة وأمن مواطنينا ،
عقدت وزارة الدفاع من خلال
القيادة الشمالية والقيادة في ألاسكا
حافة القطب الشمالي 2018 لضمان
تدريب جيشنا وتجهيزه للعمل بأمان
في بيئات القطب الشمالي
هذا العالم غير مؤكد
يتوقع كبار قادتنا أنه
يجب علينا بناء الاستعداد على أساس يومي
، وبالتالي فإن الغرض من التمرين هو
التأكد من أن لدينا تقديرًا لمكان وجود
البنية التحتية الحيوية في ألاسكا
والتأكد من استعدادنا و
اتخذ موقفًا حيال ما إذا كان مطلوبًا
لإجراء الطوارئ
بنجاح ، فنحن نوعاً ما نتحقق من صحة
كيفية تحركنا في بيئات قاسية
وخاصة كيفية المضي قدمًا والازدهار في
عمليات الطقس شديد البرودة ،
ما يقرب من 1500 جندي من البحارة
ومشاة البحرية من 20 وحدة موجودة
عبر  اجتمعت الولايات المتحدة
لتنفيذ حافة القطب الشمالي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لا يمكننا أن نتقدم بها  و آه ، لا
يوجد مكان آخر لا يمكننا فيه الأداء
بشكل جيد ، فنحن دائمًا أقوى معًا ولا
توجد قوة مثل القوة
المشتركة ، وإذا مارسنا معًا ،
سنكون أكثر قدرة إذا ذهبنا للقيام
بذلك بشكل حقيقي في أي مكان في  العالم
الذي لا نعرف أين
سننشر بعد ذلك ، لا نعرف
الخدمات الشقيقة التي سنضطر إلى العمل بها
مع الإغلاق مع
حافة القطب الشمالي للعدو ، كما قدمت
فرصة فريدة لدمج
قوات العمليات
الخاصة والتقليدية  كان الجنود ومشاة البحرية
يعملون
في فصيلة مشاة تقليدية
وكانوا قادرين على معرفة
أنك تعرف تنظيم المهمة ثم
كيف يعمل الانهيار
الهيكلي ، ثم أيضًا كيفية الاندماج في تلك
الوحدات لخدمة الغرض على أفضل وجه
لاستيعاب المهمة
التي استغرقها ما يقرب من ثلاثة عقود
منذ آخر
تمرين عسكري مشترك واسع النطاق في القطب الشمالي
والدروس المستفادة من هذا
التمرين
ستوجه تطوير تقنيات
وإجراءات تكتيكية  سيتم استخدامها خلال حافة القطب الشمالي
لمزيد من المعلومات حول التزامنا العسكري